Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Fünfzehnte Folge von, nein, die Sechzehnte. Es geht voran. Die sechzehnte Folge.
Sechzehnte Folge.
Netzpolitik, da haben wir ja schon eine binär Potenz äh vervollständigt.
Da freut sich der Nerd.
Diesmal auch wieder im äh Studio vereint. Letzte Mal haben wir da so ein bisschen äh Skype-Experimente gemacht.
Da war leider die Qualität jetzt äh gestern mit unserem Gast nicht äh letztes Mal mit dem Gast nicht,
nicht, nicht, nicht, nicht optimal, aber auch nicht zerstörerisch schlecht.
Es sei mir hier der kleine Seitenhieb erlaubt, dass wir, glaube ich, noch eine bessere Qualität hatten, als Fefe bei seiner Alternativlosfolge.
Selbstverständlich.
Wurde, glaube ich, in das Mikrofon äh an.
Der hatte das hatte irgendwie die falsche das falsche Input äh geschaltet und hat dann da in sein Laptop, Mikrofon gelabert und der die ganze Zeit mit der Tastatur drüber geklimpert. Wir wir sind besser. Ädsch.
Verstehe. Wir sind besser. Ein Klassiker.
Dann äh wollen wir das mal unter Beweis stellen. Womit geht's los.
Äh ja. Wir hatten ja vor, ich glaube in Folge zwölf, also vor ungefähr einem Monat,
wir über dieses Max-Planck-Instituts Gutachten zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung gesprochen.
Wir erinnern uns das zentrale Ergebnis dieser Studie,
vom Bundesministerium der Justiz in Auftrag gegeben worden war, war
Es nicht zu belegen ist, dass die Aufklärung von Verbrechen
gelitten hat, nachdem die Forstdatenspeicherung abgeschafft wurde, da gab's ja irgendwie,
schönen Vergleich mit anderen Ländern, äh wie sich das da entwickelt hat und äh einfach mal
empirisch geschaut auf die Aufklärungsquoten,
Und äh ja, wir haben ja schon angekündigt, dass wir haben ja schon damit gerechnet, dass diese Studie jetzt irgendwie nicht lange da stehen würde, ohne dass irgendjemand dem dieses äh Ergebnis nicht passt.
Etwas finden wird, um da etwas entgegenzusetzen. Und jetzt stellt sich heraus,
erste Version der Studie an das äh BMJ,
und das Ergebnis dieser Studie war,
Nämlich genau das gegenteilige Ergebnis, dass Sie,
keine Kritik an der Vorratsdatenspeicherung geübt haben, sondern ähm,
sehr stark dafür gedrängt haben, dass die wieder eingeführt wird.
Und äh diese Studie landete also dann auf dem äh auf den Schreibtischen des Bundesjustizministeriums.
Und ähm wurde dann vom Bundesjustizministerium zurückgewiesen. Und ähm,
also gesagt, passt mal auf, hier ähm methodisch möchten wir bitte,
ihr andere Dinge damit erfasst. Ähm,
stellte sich heraus, dass diese Studie äh allein auf Gesprächen mit Vertretern von Polizei und Staatsanwälten basierte. Das heißt, sie haben also so eine Interviewstudie gemacht, dass äh,
was ist denn jetzt alles äh schlecht, seitdem die Vorratsdatenspeicherung weg ist? Dann haben die gesagt, ja ähm.
Hier brauchen wir alles, muss alles zurück. Und ähm entsprechend fiel dann auch die Studie aus.
Und äh ja, das Bundesjustizministerium sagte dann eben, ja also Freunde, ne, so geht's nicht. Ähm nehmt mal bitte ähm ermittlungseffizienz und Aufklärungsquote mit auf, also als wirklich messbare, empirisch messbare Daten,
und das möchten wir bitte als Schwerpunkt dieser Studie sehen und,
Außerdem verwendet ihr mal bitte hier schön Daten aus dem Jahr zweitausendneun und macht da mal einen vernünftigen Vergleich draus.
Und jetzt findet die CSU das aber total doof.
Die CSU sagt jetzt, äh ja, hier Manipulation der Studie und äh verhindert seit einiger Zeit, dass der Studienleiter Hans-Jörg Albrecht das Ding überhaupt im Innenausschuss äh des Bundestags mal vorstellen kann seine Studie
und äh ja, feuert da jetzt natürlich relativ ähm scharf auf die,
Justizministerin Sabine Leuthauser Schnarrenberger und,
hier meine Lieblingsfreunde von der äh deutsch,
Ah nee, diesmal nicht DPG, sondern GTP. Gewerkschaft der Polizei, nein, meine anderen Freunde. Ähm die sagen jetzt sogar, ähm,
Dass die Bundesregierung Stellung beziehen soll und wenn der Vorwurf zutrifft, dann habe sie hier sich eine Gefälligkeitsstudie erstellen lassen und ähm,
wer in ihrem Amt nicht mehr tragbar, weil sie gegen das Wesentliche Instrument der Verbrechen,
kämpfung gekämpft hat, als Justizministerin und,
Ja, also da da geht's jetzt heiß her. Ne, also die haben jetzt offensichtlich bemühen sich jetzt da, da richtig gegen zu feuern und.
Ja, wirklich auch schon auf die Person. Fun, fun,
Rande. Zweitausendsieben hatte die damalige Justizministerin,
Brigitte Zypries von der SPD äh dass ein erstes Max-Planck-Gutachten zurückgehalten,
weil es ihr zu kritisch ausgefallen ist. Also die bei ihr was genau andersrum,
offensichtlich um wissenschaftliche Gutachten zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung möchte man sich, wenn ich das jetzt so sehe, äh sich als äh Sozialwissenschaftler echt nicht reißen,
weil ähm da die wissenschaftliche ähm.
Die wissenschaftliche Arbeit sehr ins Kreuzfeuer der politischen Interessen gerät.
Ja mit den wissenschaftlichen Studien scheint es ähnlich zu sein wie mit den Statistiken, ja, also äh bloß keine Veröffentlichen, die man nicht selbst in irgendeiner Form beeinflusst hat und äh manipuliert hat
wenn die Aussage der Wissenschaftler einem passt, dann werden gleich die Festreden gehalten und hier wissenschaftliche Belege bla bla bla. Und äh sobald die Wissenschaft mal zu anderen Erkenntnissen kommt, dann ist das ja alles äh beiest und äh geht ja gar nicht und äh das muss man auch nochmal politisch bewerten und bla, bla, bla.
Wenn ich wenn ich mir die wenn ich mir die die Kritikpunkte, die jetzt da ich habe jetzt nicht beide Studien äh im Detail verglichen, aber ähm gemeldet, also so im im Spiegel und bei Heise und,
Vom AK Vorrat gibt's einen längeren Beitrag dazu, haben wir natürlich auch alles wieder verlinkt. Ähm.
Jemand mir eine Studie gibt, in der er nur äh Staatsanwälte und Polizei zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
befragt. Ähm.
Würde ich auch nicht akzeptieren. Also das ist wirklich keine ernstzunehmende wissenschaftliche Methodik. Ähm dass man sagt, ich möchte gerne empirische Daten haben, halte ich in dem,
was ich bis jetzt darüber gelesen habe und dass man sagt, wenn wir das bewerten möchten,
möchten wir bitte ermittlungseffizienz und Aufklärungsquote als relevante Variablen in dieser Studie vertreten haben
denke ich, ist eine äußerst valide Kritik an einer äh wissenschaftlichen Studie, solange dieses Defizit auch tatsächlich bestanden hat, kann man hier, glaube ich, nicht von äh Einflussnahme sprechen,
jetzt mein erster mein erster Eindruck.
Ja, aber ich würde die ursprüngliche Version jetzt mal als die Country Westernvariante äh bezeichnen, weil sowohl Polizei als auch Staatsanwaltschaftsanwaltschaft befragt wurden.
Ähm ja wie immer die Verbraucherschützer,
ähm die Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband, das muss jetzt schon sehr lange her sein, dass diese Klage da irgendwie angestrengt wurde, ist auch eher nur eine kleine Randnotiz, weil äh das ist jetzt ähm ein Landesgerichtsurteil und da wird sowieso eine Berufung geben.
Äh Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband hatte irgendwie gegen äh Facebook geklagt und da ging's ähm,
erster Stelle, um diesen Freundefinder, den Facebook ja, also ich hatte den ja, glaube ich, auch schon mal in einer der letzten Sendungen erwähnt,
dieses Hochladen meines Adressbuchs, damit äh Facebook dann die Leute spamen kann.
Mhm.
Meine Kritik war ja hauptsächlich daran, dass Facebook da Profile über Menschen anlegt,
und ähm jetzt gab's also ein Urteil des Landesgerichts Berlins. Das also sagte dieser bei diesem machen sind der Nutzer und Facebook Mittäter einer direkt Werbung. Das heißt, sie spammen gemeinsam.
Eine Interpretation, die ich eigentlich echt ganz einleuchtend finde, weil ähm ich gebe ja Facebook oder also der Facebook Nutzer gibt Facebook Adressen,
damit Facebook diese Adressen dann kann, ja? Also dieser dieser Interpretation kann man,
als Laie folgen. Der äh Rechtsanwalt Thomas Stadler hat dann schon direkt,
dass das eben eine Mittäterschaft da aus juristischen Überlegungen eigentlich nicht, wenn dann geht's irgendwie um eine Teilnehmerschaft oder.
Man bildet sozusagen mit Facebook in dem Moment, wo man sein Adressbuch hochlädt, so eine kriminelle Organisation, das ist so die These, ja. Ah ja.
Also so was, was ist da, wie gesagt, ich ich kann mir also.
Organisierte Kriminalität leicht gemacht. Sogar das dabei hilft äh Facebook. Nicht nur beim E-Mail und äh beim Veröffentlichen von Veranstaltungen.
Genau. Also ähm,
Anwalt, der diese Sache einschätzt, dass er Mittäterschaft oder oder,
Erfüllungsgift oder sowas, wahrscheinlich die falsche äh die falsche, der falsche Begriff ist, sondern eher Teilnehmer.
Was auch immer, also so genau, also es gibt auf jeden Fall an diesem äh Vorgehen,
Kritik, die auch äh offensichtlich sich in den deutschen,
in den deutschen Gesetzen wiederspiegelt.
Aber dieser wird in dieser Form von Facebook in Deutschland ohnehin nicht mehr gemacht,
relativ egal jetzt im im Nachlauf, da dagegen keine Veränderungen mit einher und dann stand in der ähm.
Aber die, aber das, die haben jetzt nicht nur geklagt, sondern sie haben ja auch Recht bekommen.
Ja, sie haben Recht bekommen. Die Klage ist alt, jetzt wurde irgendwie das Urteil gesprochen und da haben sie Recht bekommen. Und äh zweiter Punkt war das die Richter der Auffassung sind, dass die Einwilligungserklärung, mit der die Nutzer,
der Datenverarbeitung zu Werbezwecken zustimmen.
Irgendwie rechtswidrig rechtswidrig sei.
Ähm wenn man das jetzt äh mal so interpretieren will, äh wörtlich, dann,
Könnte man das natürlich so auslegen, dass es heißt, okay, dass Facebook überhaupt äh,
Daten zu Werbezwecken ausnutzt äh ist ja ihr einziges Geschäftsmodell.
Und äh dass dieses Geschäftsmodell oder.
Äh Einwilligungserklärungen, die zum Basis dieses Geschäftsmodells gemacht wird, äh rechtswidrig sei. Ähm,
Man kann sich vorstellen, dass äh das sicherlich etwas sehr hoch gegriffen ist in der Interpretation und dass Facebook das nicht lange auf sich sitzen lassen wird,
Berufung.
Aber im Prinzip hat sich das Gericht, welches Gericht war denn das eigentlich.
Gericht Berlin.
Naja, ähm.
Im Prinzip haben die sich gegen diese durchaus ja weit verbreitete und nicht nur bei Facebook weit verbreitete Praxis ausgesprochen, dass,
ja schon zu weit ginge. Jetzt kann man da zwei.
Drauf haben. Ich denke, es gibt so diese äh etwas panische äh äh Blickweise im Sinne von,
oh Gott, alles, was ich jetzt da einstelle, verschenke ich automatisch, ja und dann darf mit mir Werbung gemacht werden.
Ähm eine nachvollziehbares Bedrohungsszenario. Auf der anderen Seite stehen so die Interessen des Systemanbieters, ja, also was wäre, wenn du jetzt ein,
solches äh Netzwerk aufbauen wolltest, da willst du ja nicht dich bei Millionen von Usern bei jeglicher minimalen Nutzung und Einblendung in einem anderen Kontext et cetera immer wieder um eine entsprechende Freigabe bemühen
also es ist ja quasi auch so das einräumen einer einer bestimmten Handlungsfreiheit, jetzt mal so der.
Was man auch so auf den ersten Blick durchaus nachvollziehen kann. Die Frage ist, ob das Landesgericht Berlin jetzt hier in irgendeiner Form.
Auch zu einer Änderung beitragen kann.
Ähm.
Wann war das? Das ist jetzt vom sechsten März.
Der dritte. Ja. Also.
Das Landesgerichts Berlin wird da nicht zu irgendeiner Veränderung beitragen können, weil es sofort natürlich in eine Berufung geht und irgendeinen OLG oder das nächsthöhere Gericht äh Urteil da erwartet wird, wenn.
Wenn jetzt also.
Kommt man natürlich irgendwann an den Punkt, dass äh dass das ein Präzedenzfall ist und sich da was ändern muss,
ähm ich denke jetzt erstmal wird Facebook ganz klar sagen, ja sofort anfechten, Berufung und so weiter.
Und äh in naher Zukunft wird sich da erstmal gar nichts ändern. Und äh in der Form, wie es jetzt zumindest in der äh Pressemitteilung da dargestellt wird, denke ich, dass das auch nicht das ähm.
Das letzte, das das letzte Wort in der Angelegenheit auf jeden Fall irgendwie differenzierter sein wird,
nicht besonders gut halten. Also da wird sich noch irgendwas ändern. Da da fängt jetzt eine ein größerer Rechtsstreit an.
Na ja, wir beobachten das. Wir erwähnen das ja nur, damit wir später sagen können, dass wir das erst schon mal erfinden.
Genau, da ging's jetzt mal los. VZBV hat hat es mal geschafft, ja.
LNP berichtete.
Damit wir das schon mal ein Leistungsschutzrecht auf die Angelegenheit haben, wollte ich das mal mit aufnehmen.
Auf dem letzten Kongress vor allem, nicht nur dort, aber da äh fiel es mir persönlich das erste Mal eigentlich so richtig auf. Ich habe das noch nicht so richtig aufn Zeiger gehabt, um ehrlich zu sein, ich hab's immer noch nicht so richtig aufn Zeiger.
Ähm dass ich irgendwie aus aus vielen ähm Partnern zusammensetzt,
ich schaue jetzt mal gerade ganz kurz, wer da so alles mit dabei ist, da sind also alle großen Namen irgendwie,
Okay, jetzt große Namen. Ja, hier, Fuji Fuji zu IBM, Intel, Microsoft, ORR,
Siemens, Techniker, Krankenkasse, äh Hannover sechsundneunzig
das ist gleich das Logo von Hannover sechsundneunzig, Antivir ähm.
Hannover sechsundneunzig.
Ja, oder? Ist das ein Fußballverein, oder? Hannovers.
Gegen so was scheiß so ein Mailing rum und irgendjemand meinte so, oh hier, das ist gegen Kinderpornografie, das machen wir mit, das kann nicht schlecht sein, ne?
Mach mal mit, mach mal mit. Ärztekammer Niedersachsen.
Das ist schon erstaunlich, dass auch Hannover sechsundneunzig da sein äh IT-Gewicht in die Waagschale wirkt.
Ja, das also dann ist alles verloren, ja. Äh der Brancheverband Bitcom, den man natürlich kennt, dann der,
das letzte Mal aufgefallen, weil sie,
allerdings auch äh freiwillige Selbstkontrolle Multimedia. Also da ist eine ganze Menge äh drin, also eigentlich fast alles große.
Nokia Siemens Networks. Die Jungs, die die schönen ähm Überwachungstechniken ins Ausland liefern.
Sind alle, alle großen irgendwie drin vertreten und dieses Bündnis möchte sich eben der der Kinderpornografie beziehungsweise deren Bekämpf.
Okay und und wie bekämpfen die das jetzt?
Ja, indem sie sich äh,
Einfach mal so mit mit technischen Lösungen und,
setzen sich eben also wollen sich irgendwie effizient mit deren Bekämpfung auseinandersetzen. Erstmal,
keine äh keine so blöde Idee.
Und jetzt gab's also am beim Kongress einen Vortrag von äh Christian Bahls, der äh vom Moges EV ist,
Ich glaube, das ist der Gründer des Moges EV. Äh Missbrauchsopfer gegen Internetsperren.
Dass äh er ist auf jeden Fall also die einzige.
Dass die sichtbare Person. Ähm.
Jetzt hat er, also der hat also dann kritisiert, dass äh er den tatsächlichen Schutz von Opfern dort immer weiter in den Hintergrund treten sieht und ähm das,
die Kontroll- und Überwachungsinfrastrukturen beinhalten, da langsam an Übersicht gewinnen. Da hat er also einen Vortrag gehalten beim äh beim
Kongress beim achtundzwanzig C3, den ich ähm,
der der erschien mir ein bisschen sehr schwarz malerisch oder so ein bisschen Panik,
ähm hundert Prozent ernst genommen und zwar sprach er dann davon, dass,
was offensichtlich gemacht wird, ist, dass Behörden.
Möglichkeit ein einer Datei, einer Art Fingerabdruck zu verpassen. Das heißt, da wird eine ähm wird mit den Bits in der Datei eine bestimmte,
ähm kryptographische Operation gemacht, vollzogen, an deren Ende ein immer gleich langer ähm,
Ist dann, glaube ich, zweiunddreißig äh zweiunddreißig Zeichen lang und das ist,
mit sehr hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit ändert sich diese Prüfsumme, sobald sich auch nur ein Bit an der Datei ändert.
Zweiunddreißig hoch, sechzehn Möglichkeiten gibt. Also man kann sich das vorstellen als Fingerabdruck einer ähm Fingerabdruck einer Datei,
Ähm.
Und diese diese Hesh-Werte kommen üblicherweise eigentlich zum Einsatz, um die Integrität von Dateien zu,
Man lädt also was weiß ich eine eins Komma vier Gigabyte Datei runter und kriegt gleichzeitig dann noch den
dazu gesagt und dann berechnet man bei seiner heruntergeladenen Datei diesen Wert und wenn der gleich ist, dann weiß man, okay, diese Datei ist unbeschädigt, ich kann,
jetzt mal in zwei Minuten zusammengefasst, was ein ist. Und jetzt haben die Ermittlungsbehörden angefangen und haben gesagt, naja, wir haben so viel ähm.
Illegale Dateien, also bleiben wir jetzt mal beim Thema Kinderpornografie. Es gibt so viel.
Kinderpornografisches Material,
und das wiederholt sich ja auch. Das wird ja irgendwie getauscht und das heißt, ein ein Bild oder so, das haben wahrscheinlich dann eben sehr, sehr viele Menschen,
und dann haben sie also gesagt, okay, wir fangen an, eine Hesh-Datenbank zu machen, also eine Datenbank mit genau diesen Fingerabdrücken.
Die wird aktuell zum Beispiel dafür genutzt, wenn man also einen Computer beschlagnahmt
durchsucht einfach alle Dateien, berechnet die und prüft, ob irgendwelche bekannten Dateien drin sind. Das heißt, man kann damit so ein bisschen die,
Durchsuchung von beschlagnahmten Computern ähm gut beschleunigen. Ähm und jetzt bei diesem ähm,
kommt quasi diese Idee, diese Datenbank in Verbindung in in Kontakt zu,
Leuten, die andere Techniken herstellen. Beispielsweise ähm der Freunde von IT-Watch, die also so ein bisschen, die machen so Endpoint Security Produkte.
Ähm das heißt, äh sie machen zum Beispiel äh Signatur oder hashbasierte Verfahren, um zu,
ist nicht nicht besonders unterschieden vom Vorgehen eines Virenscanners,
ähm die IT Edition ihrer Security Suite vorgestellt zusammen mit dem niedersächsischen Innenminister Schünemann.
Und das äh das funktioniert also so, wenn ich wenn ich diese YT Edition auf meinem Rechner installiert habe und dann versuche, eine Datei zu öffnen,
Dann wird geprüft, ob's diese Datei einen Hash hat,
in dieser Datenbank vorhanden ist. Und wenn das denn der Fall ist,
dann wird die kann man also eine Aktion feststellen, was weiß ich, Datei wird gelöscht oder äh E-Mail an den Systemadministrator oder an die Polizei oder sonst was, kann man kann man eben irgendwas machen
in wenigen Zeilen gecodet, aber ähm,
IT-Watch äh will dieses will diese Idee jetzt irgendwie ähm kommerzialisieren,
und streben an, dass so etwas eingebaut wird in äh Betriebssysteme.
Das ist also deren erklärtes Ziel, was ihnen auch bei der äh Cebit so gesagt haben, also das ist ihr quasi ihre ihre Monetarisierungsidee ist, dass die großen Betriebssystemhersteller diese Technik in ihre Betriebssysteme einbauen.
Also quasi Spionagesoftware direkt ins OS äh mit einbauen.
Dann könntest du quasi so Windows Windows neun White Edition.
Ja und der der zieht sich dann irgendwie regelmäßig seine seine Updates von von irgend 'n Server einer riesigen Datenbank, ich will nicht wissen wie viele.
Ja. Also ich meine, tatsächlich gibt es diese Software bereits im Betriebssystem. Ja, das ist äh ja in dem Sinne nichts Neues. Die Frage ist nur,
sind die Aktionen und was sind die, ne? Derzeit wird halt nach
gesucht oder eben aus anderen Gründen gefährliche Software und,
Sobald ich weiß, geht's da auch primär erst mal um Executives, also es wird nur Software,
ausführbarer Code analysiert, aber natürlich ist der Vorgang der Überprüfung anderer Dateien genauso einfach,
Man kann sich das natürlich jetzt äh auch gleich noch weiterdenken, weil diese Heschmethodik spielt natürlich gerade,
jetzt angestrebten Cloud.
Konstellationen natürlich eine große Rolle. Allein schon als Effizienzgründen,
werden diese äh Hashes halt gebildet, um einfach festzustellen, ob eine Datei schon mal hochgeladen werden soll oder nicht, ja, das heißt, da basiert sehr viel auf solchen.
Ich glaube, das muss man nochmal kurz äh muss nochmal kurz genauer erklären. Also warum soll die hochgeladen werden, warum nicht?
Ja sie soll halt äh hochladen kostet immer Zeit, ja und äh äh es ist sehr viel einfacher festzustellen, dass die Datei bereits irgendwo in der Wolke existiert und ähm das kann man eben mit so einem hash,
zumindest glaubt man, dass äh in den meisten Fällen, dass es zuverlässig funktioniert, kann man eben sagen, noch wieso haben wir ja schon.
Also Beispiel ist äh Dropbox, wenn hundertachtzig Leute eine Datei in ihrer Dropbox haben, dann will,
möglichst die Datei nur einmal auf seiner Festplatte haben und nicht ähm hundertachtzig Mal. Und dafür nutzen.
Wäre man jetzt ein Systemadministrator, ein solches eines solchen Systems, wäre es mal wirklich eine interessante äh Statistik zu sehen,
sind denn jetzt eigentlich die Dateien, die hier am meisten,
vertreten sind, ne? Also man kann in so einem System sehr einfach
populärste Datei feststellen,
man weiß dann ja auch eigentlich gleich, worum es sich handelt, weil man hat
die Datei ja auch im Zugriff, wenn man denn wollte, ja, also ich will jetzt hier keinem irgendwas unterstellen, aber das ist natürlich das Wesen eines Cloud Systems, das es eben möglichst effizient äh äh Dateien vorhält.
Und da ja jetzt auch die Telekom
anderem da äh anstrebt, solche Dienste zu machen. Wir alle wissen, wie das immer ist mit der Nähe solcher Unternehmen zu äh so Staats,
itäten, nicht wahr, seien's elektronische Versionen, irgendwelche Pässe, et cetera, die E-Mail und das ist ja so ein
eine riesige Wolke an solchen Diensten, ja,
zu uns, hier ist irgendwie alles staatsgeprüft und lizensiert.
Ich denke, dass solche Ideen an der Stelle sehr viel schneller verfangen, ne? Dass man jetzt Apple davon überzeugen kann,
Datenbank und Überprüfungsvorgehen ins Betriebssystem einzubauen. Ich glaube, das ist,
eher unrealistisch. Ähm.
Aber es zeigt sich mal wieder, dass solche Bedürfnisse natürlich da sind. Zum Schutze der Kinder.
Ich habe mir jetzt grade so vorgestellt, so diese die wöchentlichen Dropbox Charts, der beliebten der beliebtesten Dateien,
Wäre auf jeden Fall nochmal irgendwie eine Seite, die ich mir regelmäßig angucken würde, sondern die deutschen Dropbox-Charts, die die US-Dropbox-Charts, so was ist gerade der heiße Shit so, was man was welche Datei muss man gerade haben so, wenn man was auf sich zählt,
und ähm,
Ansonsten ist vielleicht noch kurz dazu zu sagen so ein basiertes Verfahren ähm,
Also ich frage mich ehrlich, was wie dieser IT-Watch vorziehst, da irgendwo, wo die ihren Mehrwert sehen, ja, also im Vergleich zu einem Virenscanner, ist so ein so ein Abgleich von. Wie gesagt, das Ding schreibe ich dir in drei Zeilen, ja?
Errechne ob er in der Datenbank ist, führe Aktion aus,
Also ich ich frage mich jetzt, was die meinen, dass sie ihr Produkt irgendwie zur Monetarisierung,
ihr macht hier und vergleicht die krass wie viele Millionen wollt ihr haben, damit wir diese tolle Idee in unser Betriebssystem am besten auf
Ebene oder was äh einbauen können.
Ja, ich will da keinem was unterstellen, aber das klingt natürlich auch so ein bisschen einfach nach Wichtigmacherei.
Im Vergleich zu zu dem was heutzutage so ein Virenscanner macht, ist der Vergleich von hashes echt ein relativ primitiver Ansatz, ne, muss man also von der technischen Seite, aber die Idee,
wir wissen's ja immer, wenn irgendwo von Kinderpornografie die Rede ist, dann,
sind auch immer die jene Leute nicht weit, die davor waren, dass sie sagen, dass so eine Technik natürlich auch,
anderen äh bei anderen Thematiken zum Einsatz kommen könnte und
sagen wir mal ein Betriebssystem, was meinen Rechner auf die Existenz bestimmter Dateien prüft und diese löscht ähm
ein sehr, sehr schwerwiegender Eingriff in die Integrität meines äh Betriebssystemes. Zumal man dazu sagen muss, ab einer, das spielt eigentlich Prax in der praktischen Anwendung von hash äh Funktionen bis heute
keine entscheidende, große Rolle. Äh und das sind Kollisionen,
es ist natürlich möglich, ja, wenn man jetzt überlegt, es gibt irgendwie,
zweiunddreißig hoch sechzehn Möglichkeiten, es gibt aber natürlich mehr Variationen in der Möglichkeit, was eine Datei sein kann. Das heißt, es gibt zwei Dateien, zwei unterschiedliche Dateien, die ein und den gleichen Hash haben. Ähm das ist, wie gesagt, ähm,
in der bisherigen Anwendung von keine kein so großes Problem.
Zumindest was die was das Verwechseln von Dateien angeht,
aber es gibt diese Möglichkeit und das wäre für dieses für dieses IT-Watch natürlich auch ein Problem, wenn ich dann irgendwann,
versehentlich irgendwie jeder millionenste Nutzer irgendwie sein Word-Dokument gelöscht bekommt, weil es äh den falschen Hash hat.
Und man dafür auch noch gleich irgendwie äh einen Klage an den Hals kriegt.
Ist zumindest also ein Szenario, dass sie sich Gedanken machen wollen. Ganz kurz noch zu den Hashes ähm ich habe vor einigen Wochen mit dem,
Markus Richter, ein Podcast aufgenommen, die Wahrheit Nummer elf zum Thema Online-Festplatten,
wir uns ein bisschen äh mehr noch mit solchen Dingen auseinandergesetzt, den verlinke ich dann auch.
Mhm.
Verlassen wir mal hier unsere äh Insel Deutschland und.
Politischen Verstrickungen begeben wir uns mal wieder auf internationales Terrain. Da gab's dann mal wieder äh ja enorme geheimdienstliche Aktivitäten und äh unter anderem ist die Hackergruppe,
im letzten Jahr durch ein paar, ja, spektakuläre Hackaktionen auffällig wurde, äh so ein bisschen den Bach runtergegangen. Was ist passiert?
Äh für diejenigen, denen das jetzt kein Begriff ist, das waren also,
und die haben eben, wie Tim grade schon sagte, im letzten Jahr, einige ganz spektakuläre Hacks gemacht, die haben da irgendwie weiß ich nicht, die Webseite vom,
äh gehackt und da irgendwie eine Meldung verbreitet. Tupac Sharko lebt jetzt in Neuseeland
und äh dann haben sie irgendwie kurz nach dem Sony PlayStation Network Heck Sony die Seite von Sony,
gehackt, dann haben sie die Webseite des US-Senats gehackt, ähm dann haben sie,
dann haben sie sich erstmal aufgelöst und dann haben sie aber irgendwie unter dem Label Antisek äh so ein bisschen weitergemacht und irgendwie,
in der Web auf der Webseite der sun irgendwie den Tod von äh,
verkündet und solche Sachen. Ähm und die haben eigentlich immer mit den Hacks gingen immer einher, dass die dann irgend so ein,
so ein Dödeltext auf veröffentlicht haben und ein Torent mit allen Dateien irgendwie unredigiert
alles äh rausgerutzt und dazu irgendwie so einen Text geschrieben, so guck mal hier haben wir.
Und äh also das war wirklich, das war eigentlich alles, was die gemacht haben, so völlig ohne ähm ohne irgendwie.
Irgendeine martialische, politische Agenda oder so, sondern wirklich einfach nur, ja zum Lachen, irgendwie irgendwo eingebrochen,
rausgeholt, äh gepastet und gesagt, so ähm guck mal, was wir gemacht haben.
So und das war also ein Grüppchen, die ähm wie gesagt, eine ganze Reihe an großen und kleinen Hacks gemacht haben und die hatten also,
ähm wie würde man sagen? Ähm,
Cojones. Die haben also die haben einfach echt äh sich mit allen angelegt und äh,
dann auch relativ schnell ähm kontrovers,
Aber sie haben eben echt äh ja, sie haben,
äh asozialen Art dann einfach äh auf gerotzt so.
Selbstverständlich.
Wo sich den dem ethischen äh Hacker der CCC-Prägung schnell mal die Fußnägel hochrollt.
Da rollen sich schnell die Fußnägel hoch ähm und ähm wie sich jetzt also herausstellte, waren diese Jungs oder einer dieser Jungs auch hinter diesem Strat vor Hack ähm,
wohl daran beteiligt, der ja auch äh sage ich mal in CCC Reihen eher,
etwas kritischer damals aufgefasst wurde, der davon sprachen wir schon letzte Woche,
schließe ich nämlich jetzt auch darauf an. Zwar wollte ich einmal kurz so ein bisschen erzählen, wie die sich diese Jungs geschnappt haben.
Und zwar hatten sie den Sabu. Ähm das war so der,
einer der Oberhelden, so im enormen und Umfeld. Ähm den hatten sie schon seit Juni zweitausendelf äh vom FBI kontrolliert.
Haben sie sich irgendwie geschnappt ähm wie sie's am Ende gemacht haben, da gibt's mehrere äh Überlegungen zu einer.
Er wurde irgendwie mehrfach schon gedoxt, also von irgendwelchen Leuten ins Internet gestellt, dass.
Es also auch wäre.
Und einer der Fehler, der ihm irgendwie unterlaufen ist, ist, dass er eine anonyme Domain hatte.
Und durch irgendeinen Fehler bei der Verlängerung seines Domainvertrages,
irgendwie für einen Tag sein tatsächlicher richtiger Name in der äh DNS-Registration,
einer der vielen Fehler, die irgendwie offensichtlich auf ihn gedeutet haben,
wie das FBI ihn genau habhaft geworden ist, ist darüber die Legenden, auf jeden Fall Juli zweitausendelf schon.
Ähm hat das FBI bei dem an die Tür geklopft und hat gesagt, guck mal hier, mein Freund, äh du hast ja hier zwei Kinder und ähm,
Die wachsen ja jetzt auch auf und möchte sie doch wahrscheinlich auch miterleben, ne? Und ähm,
setzt sich doch jetzt mal bitte wieder zurück an deinen Computer,
und äh chatte mal weiter mit deinen Freunden und hier, ne, das ist hier Sargent oder oder Officer oder sonst was,
so und so, der setzt sich jetzt einfach mal neben dich. Der hat so ein kleines Notizbuch und äh der macht sich ein bisschen Notizen.
Dass er jetzt seit Juni zweitausendelf, ja? Ähm im Juni hatte sich Lifestyle,
ähm damals schon aufgelöst eigentlich,
Und Sabu war auch schon mal einen Monat weg vom Fenster,
das heißt den den gab's irgendwie einen Monat lang nicht und dann war er auf einmal wieder da und sagte ja ja alles in Ordnung, ich war was weiß ich im Urlaub oder so oder ich bin untergetaucht na ja das war halt genau der Monat
wo er dann mit dem FBI mal so über den übers Aufwachsen seiner Kinder ein ernsthaftes Gespräch geführt hatte.
So und der saß also seit Juni zweitausendelf hat jeder, der sich irgendwie mit Sabo unterhalten hat, äh sich,
Einer der engen, einer der engen, einer der engen Bezugspersonen, die sich da so mit dem Sabo ausgetauscht haben, war äh,
Jeremy Hamilt.
Und so weiter. Klar, ganz konspirativ. Und der ist jetzt angeklagt für den äh Stradfor Hack, den wir ja auch schon äh erwähnt hatten.
Wo die Kreditkarten abgesogen wurden.
Genau und irgendwie Geld an gute Zwecke gespendet wurde und.
Userdatenbank veröffentlicht.
Userdatenbanken veröffentlicht und wo jetzt diese ganzen eBays bei Wiki Leaks landen. Äh.
Netzpolitik berichtete. Auch hier äh was Folge fünfzehn war das dann, ne? Ja.
Und äh den haben sie dann irgendwie, das fand ich auch ganz interessant, wie sie ihn denn eingekreist hatten. Er hatte also dem Sabo oder oder,
im Chat mal erzählt, weiß ich, dass letzte Woche Bekannte von ihm bei einer politischen
in welchem Bundesstaat die stattgefunden hatte
zweitausendvier beim Republic National bei der Republic In National Convention verhaftet worden war.
Dass er mal im Knast war für einen Hack, äh dass er mal Ärger hatte wegen äh Marihuana-Besitz, dass er gerade auf Bewährung ist,
und dass er ab und zu ganz gerne mal Containern geht, also äh Nahrungsmittel aus äh den Abfallcontainern von Supermärkten holt.
Und da stand dann irgendwie auch in irgendwelchen Überwachungsprotokollen äh in Ermittlungsakten gegen ihn. Das heißt, die,
FBI musste eigentlich nur so einkreisen, ne? Wer wurde irgendwann mal verhaftet, wer hatte da und da,
an der Hand und dann sind sie halt bei ihnen nach Hause gefahren, haben da irgendwie äh.
Ein FBI Fuzzi vor die Tür gestellt und der hat die ganze Zeit geguckt, wann er die Wohnung verlässt und wann nicht,
außerdem die Aktivität seines WLANs äh gemessen. Also das WLAN war vermutlich verschlüsselt, aber sie konnten ja sehen, wann wird auf dieser Frequenz,
gesendet und dann haben sie so ganz billiges Timing gemacht, immer irgendwie so, okay, der ist gerade aus dem Haus gegangen, ey Sabu, ähm,
den doch mal an. Ja, er antwortet, das haben sie seit ein paar Wochen gemacht. Ähm,
Und dann sind sie bei dem bei dem Jeremy reingegangen und haben gesagt, hier Kollege ähm bist jetzt verhaftet.
Spannende Sache jetzt äh sind natürlich alle völlig ähm angepisst von,
mit dem FBI kooperiert hat und ja den den mögen jetzt alle nicht mehr.
Ähm dafür sieht's aber scheinen seine Chancen im Vergleich zu ähm Jeremy Hamilt gestiegen zu sein, dass er noch seine Kinder beim Aufwachsen zuschauen kann. Und jetzt kommt der spannende Punkt. Ähm.
Bis dahin hatte eigentlich immer seine Sachen so bei reingehauen und dann irgendso ein Link zum Tourent gepostet,
so haben die ihre Daten veröffentlicht. Die haben die nie irgendwie redigiert oder so, die haben immer,
relativ dreckige einfach irgendwo reingehauen. Denen ging's ja gar nicht so unbedingt darum.
Vermarkten oder oder politisch zu nutzen, sondern wirklich einfach nur so.
Hier ist die Beute.
Hier ist die Beute, wir waren's so und wir sind die Helden.
Und dieses Drahtform-Mails, dieser Hack bei Strato, der hat also stattgefunden.
In einer Zeit, in der ähm Sabo schon von dem FBI infiltriert war,
diesem Umfeld war, liegt die Vermutung nahe, dass er davon wusste
dass Personen ihm eventuell sich über diese Sachen mit ihm ausgetauscht haben. Es gibt da auch einige Chatprotokolle, wo eben dieser Jeremy Hamind,
mit ihm darüber spricht und sagt, naja das war eine große Nummer und bei Strato haben sie ja auch nicht nur einen Server, sondern einen nach dem anderen. Die haben,
Ding ausgehoben,
Und jetzt, ausgerechnet dieses Draht-Form-Mails landen ähm paar Monate später auf einmal bei Wiki Leaks.
Und Wiki Leaks hat aber ja seit, weiß ich nicht, über einem Jahr jetzt gar kein funktionierendes Sub Mission System,
Das heißt, wenn ich möchte, dass etwas bei WikiLeaks veröffentlicht wird, habe ich die Möglichkeit, dass äh eventuell den per Post zu senden.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die noch ihr Postfach irgendwo in Australien bei irgendeiner Uni haben oder so.
Eine der weniger wahrscheinlichen. Ähm.
Wahrscheinlicher ist, dass es irgendeine Form von Kontakt gegeben hat, zwischen den Stratorhackern und äh WikiLeaks.
Und.
Wenn man jetzt fürchten würde, dass der Sabo daran beteiligt war und dabei ihm der FBI über die Schulter geschaut hat. Wie gesagt, jetzt kommen wir so ein bisschen in ins Reich der äh der äh Spekulation,
Material gesammelt wurde, was irgendwie für Wiki Leaks juristisch belastend sein,
erkundigt haben, woher das Material stammt, wenn sie eventuell sie,
Was weiß ich, gesagt haben, ach ja, Sabo, alles klar, kenne ich doch. Schön gehackt, gib mal her, hast du noch das und das und das. Ähm.
Also es könnte sein, dass da noch irgendwie, also was weiß ich, dass sie vielleicht eine Anweisung gegeben haben, nach irgendwelche bestimmten Daten angefragt haben oder vielleicht sogar Geld geboten haben,
Äh dann könnte das also sein, dass jetzt die die Ligle-Abteilung von Wiki Leaks relativ nervös wird. Und aus dieser ganzen Sache noch ähm.
Dass ich da noch irgendwann einen Nachspiel für Wiki Leaks ergibt.
Von einigen Leuten ähm da.
Also es fällt auf jeden Fall auf, dass sie es vorher nie gemacht haben. Sie haben vorher ihre Daten nicht an gegeben, sondern einfach irgendwie selber rausgerotzt. Und ähm,
stellt sich jetzt die Frage, wer hatte die Idee und warum ist das jetzt bei Wiki Leaks gelandet und wie gut kann sowas funktioniert haben, wenn neben einer der Personen nicht unbedingt die Beteiligt äh war, aber die so,
erhält in dem Bereich ist das auf jeden Fall mit ihr sich darüber ausgetauscht wurde, wenn neben einer dieser Personen.
Eben das FBI saß. Ähm andere sagen auch, dass äh dass dass das FBI-Strat vor in gewisser Weise geopfert hätte.
Also weil sie ja vermutlich davon wussten und es nicht verhindert haben.
Sondern diesen Hack irgendwie haben stattfinden lassen im Rahmen einer äh Beweissicherung oder so,
da gibt's jetzt eine ganze Menge Verschwörungstheorien. In, ich wollt's einfach nur mal erwähnen, weil wenn,
erste Institution in Deutschland, die diese Verschwörungstheorie aufgreift und dann wären wir die ersten und wenn das jetzt nicht zutrifft, dann sage ich einfach, ich habe ja gesagt, das ist eine Verschwörungstheorie,
und es war ja nur am Ende der Sendung.
Genau, wir wollen nur den Film, bitte. Wir wenden, dann wollen wir den Fame.
Wenn, dann äh wenn, dann wollen wir den Film und ansonsten.
Ansonsten die Story.
Hier noch ein Link auf dem Podcast, wie ich das richtig sehe zu dem Thema. Ähm oh, dass das.
Nee, das ist das ist das ist nicht der Podcast, ähm sondern der ein ein Text von Patrick Grey, der den Post Podcast Whiskey Business macht und ähm der äh entfaltet darin eben diese diese Theorie, dass äh.
Die Tatsache, dass Wiki Leaks das veröffentlicht hat, ähm irgendwie mit mit einer FBI,
FBI da die Finger mit im Spiel haben könnte bis zu dass das FBI das eventuell sogar angeregt haben könnte. FBI also dem dem Hector gesagt hat Hector komm jetzt hier schick das mal noch an können wir die noch direkt mit hochnehmen.
Oh Mann, ja, die Vicky League David gegen Goliath Saga nimmt auf jeden Fall äh kein Ende und gefühlt auch immer wieder weiter an Beschleunigungen zu.
Ja, also WikiLeaks ist wirklich ähm.
Fass ohne Boden.
Das ist echt äh.
Ist es auch einfach nur eine Maßnahme um uns hier. Die Themen nicht ausgehen zu lassen.
Dafür können wir auf jeden Fall dankbar sein.
Aber uns sind jetzt die Themen erstmal ausgegangen, oder?
Genau, wir sind fertig.
Es ist ja schon die zweite BDR-Protest. Oder vier ist auch dann.
Das ist schon die, je nachdem, wo man anfängt zu zählen, haben wir da schon so einige durch.
Ja
Sagen wir einfach tschüss, was?
Genau, sagen wir tschüss und machen ihr genau die unter fünfundvierzig Minuten super.
Ah, ich glaube, das sind fünfundvierzig haben wir schon noch voll bekommen. Na ja. So ist das. Bis bald. Tschau, tschau.
Tschau, tschau.